نعم عثمان نحن الان مع احد المواطنين وهو
يقوم بشراء احتياجاته من اللحوم كيف
استفدت من هذه الغنه التي اعلن عنها اعوذ
بالله من الشيطان الرجيم والحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم
طلعنا من البيوت لكي نشتري بعض اللحوم
والخضروات والفاكهه لانه الفتره الفاضيه
دي احتجنا والله كل الحاجات ما في انتهت
في البيوت والحاله بقت صعبه المويه قاطعه
والحمد لله لقينا حبنا ان شاء الله نتناول
لنا بعض الحاجات ان شاء الله نعم حتى نسال
الباعه الذين فتحوا في هذا اليوم انتم
كباعه وتوفرون كيف استفدتم من هذه الحميه
لتوفير نوعا ما اقوت للمواطنين في اثناء
هذه والله طبعا وقوت ما في السلام عليكم
فارس اسر الصديق وقود ما في وطبعا ازعار
مرتفعه
زيادات شديده اللحوم دي كنا بنجيبها
بالترحيل بعشره جنيه الليله جايبينها ب
150 جنيه
اعلى صعبه طبعا وضع صعب شديد بس ربنا يصلح
الحال ما هو السبب في ارتفاع الاسعار محمد
لو سمحت سعر الكيلو ب 5000 كيلو صافي ب
طيب ما هي الاسباب التي جعلت اسعار اللحوم
ترتفع بالنسبه عدم العقود بنزين
نشتري بالسوق الاسود
يعني ما في فاتح عشان انك تشتري منه وضع
صعب شكرا عثمان كما يعني تابعت قصه الوقود
هي قصه حيويه جدا هنا في المنطقه باعتبار
ان جميع السلعه ترتفع بانعدام الوقود اذا
كان هذا الوقود يباع بالسوق الاسود باسعار
باهضه فانه يقع عبره على المواطن البسيط
نحن الان هنا داخل السوق المركزي
لكن نلاحظ ان حيويه السوق كلها هي موجوده
على الشارع الرئيسي الذي كنا فيه قبل قليل
هنا في السوق المركزي نلاحظ نوعا من الشلل
هناك بعض المحال هي مفتوحه لكن اغلبيتها
كما نلاحظها ونراها الان هي
مغلقه ربما
الاوضاع الامنيه التي جعلت الناس عمليه
الحركه وتحرك البائعين انفسهم الذين
يبيعون هذه السلعه للناس يجدون صعوبه في
الوصول الى هذه الاسواق
وتزويد المواطنين باحتياجاتهم الرئيسيه في
هذا السوق كما ذكرت واحد من الاسواق
الرئيسيه في جنوب الخرطوم هذه الاسواق
الرئيسيه في جنوب الخرطوم تقدم خدماتها
للمواطنين
في جنوب العاصمه في غربها وشرقها الجنوبي
هنا نحن الان دخلنا نوعا من السوق هناك
بعض الباعه
يقدمون الخضروات
التي حصلوا عليها نتعرف على الوضع عندهم
نوعا ما يعني كيف استطاعوا والدوافع التي
جعلتهم ان يفتحوا وكيف احضروا هذه البضائع
الى الى السوق يعني
الان
يعني السوق كيف تحصلت على هذه البضائع وهل
كانت هناك صعوبه تواجههم كعكه كتجار
يقومون بتقديم هذه الخدمات المواطنين
والله ما نحن جاسم
للمواطنين لان الموادين ما عندهم حاجه في
واحد ظروفهم صعب شويه لابد يجي
هل كنتم مغلقين واستفدتم من هذه الهدنه
التي اعلن عنها البارحه
كنتم خلال الايام الماضيه كنتم تاتون
يوميا
وهل هناك مواطنين كانوا يشترون منكم خلال
الايام الماضيه عند عندما تكون الاشتباكات
واقعهم
بيجيبوا الحاجات بس اذا انت تنام هنا يعني
[موسيقى]
فلذلك عثمان يعني هناك عوده
للسوق نوعا ما لكنها هي عوده
نصفها بانها عوده خجوله عدد من عام في
الوضع الطبيعي هذا السوق يكون مكتظ بالله
بالباعه وبالمشترين في نفس الوقت
ويتبضعون هنا كل احتياجاتهم من خضار
وفاكهه ومن مواد تموينيه ومن لحوم ومن
اسواء اسماك
ويعتبر واحد من
الاسواق الرئيسيه التي تغذي مناطق جنوب
والشرق الخرطوم كليه حتى الى مناطق بعيده
هناك عوده فيه ربما الهدنه التي اعلن عنها
بدا الناس يحسون بمقدارها وبالتالي بدات
نوعا ما الحياه تدوب في المناطق التي
اصيبت بشلل خلال الفتره القادمه عثمان